[Music]
all right let's go out to Michigan and
talk to Michael what's up Michael hey Dr
John thank you for taking my call and
for your time of course man thanks for
calling in what's what's up man how can
the help so how do I deal with my
insecurities about my wife making three
times the amount of money I do and also
having a clear career Vision when I
don't what are you in care
about I guess it's more so like I just
feel like a
leech it's your
wife like I'm just sitting here thinking
I would do I would love it if my wife
made three times what I
make that'd be incredible so I I I I'm
I'm struggling with that it tells me
there's something beneath the money
question you feel like a leech does she
make you feel that
way no no not at all um and we're we're
pretty recently newly wet
so we're trying to figure that all out
and everything but so you're bringing
bro you're bringing some ego into
this which is funny because I don't
think I have an ego because I can't
stand myself but you know well why can't
you stand
yourself oh that's for a whole another
call nope this that's this call why
don't why can't you stand
yourself
um I can't stand how indecisive I am
about dang near everything in my life um
and I don't know when I just when I just
kind of look at myself I'm just not
happy with what I
see what in the world does your wife
find Value
in um well she really loves the fact
that um you know I I love my family and
then I'm family oriented um bull crap
bull crap on a stick you know what she
loves what
you
you dude when she said I
do she told God and you and your
families and your
friends ride or die till death till one
of us dies I
in and you immediately thought to
yourself I'm a burden
does your wife make a habit of of lying
of being
dishonest no no okay then why do you
think she's lying
now
uh I don't know here's the thing it's
all wound up together and here's why
um
there's always the occasional baseball
player who is on
deck and the guy up at bat hits the
game-winning
hit and everybody goes crazy and the
crowd cheers and everybody's jumping up
and down and he kind of feels like I
wanted to get the game when he
hit right that guy kind of sucks you
know why because they won the team
won yeah yeah and you're that guy huh
it's yeah I am and it's funny because I
preach to people that I've coached all
the time not to
be well yeah dude we we preach about I
think I wrote a book about anxiety
because that's what I that's what I
struggle with so
bad hey who who told you that you're not
worth even being married
to um a lot of
people name
them
uh you know stupid High School
classmates that
would call me a school shoo just because
I didn't talk much okay who
else
um I guess you know
every every girl that I had
relationships with that for one reason
or another didn't care for me
and decided to leave okay who
else I mean those are the two big ones
that I can think of they can't be
because you're not going to let a bunch
of moronic high school kids speak into
your
marriage you're not going to let old
girlfriends speak into your
marriage what about Mom and Dad
um they're good mom was Mom's
interesting but she loves me
and um my dad is I would say my best
friend have you ever asked your dad hey
dad do you love
me
um maybe a couple of times when I was
younger I to call him and ask him that
today okay I want you to ask him Hey Dad
are you proud of
me what would he say if you asked
that I think he would would say yes I'm
very proud of you
okay so it seems like your dad loves
you and God he's proud of you and your
wife's all
in so what is this this
facade this big scary painting you
painted over the entryway that is your
soul what is that protecting you from
high school
kids old girlfriends no what's it
protecting you
from I don't
know it sounds like it's protecting you
from feeling like you're not enough
yeah yeah I would say that that's
accurate I just didn't really know how
to put that into words what do you do
for a
living um I'm currently working in
Academia well God that's why you hate
your life just
kidding that's what I did forever look
who's talking about hey I got out homie
I'm a YouTuber now that's fair up um
like what do you what do you do in
Academia are you a professor are you an
administrator what do you do
um so I'm like an academic adviser for
student athletes okay so you're
surrounded by smart people you're
surrounded by tons of of performers just
surrounded by
unimaginable amounts of
ego and you make $32,000 a
year yeah yeah right right and everybody
asks you on a daily basis what are you
going to do what are you going to do you
going get your Masters why haven't you
get your Masters yet when are you going
to get your PhD why you and you begin to
go I don't even know if I like can hear
what do you
what yeah and then this one kid comes in
who can jump over your head standing
still and do a backflip and dunk a
basketball and he won't even go to math
class and you're like
bro the god of the universe handed you a
Wily Wonka ticket and you won't even
cash it in he's like I ain't going to
class right right
yeah
dude I spent some time with academic
advisors I know listen yeah
listen they don't get a
vote the high school kids don't get a
vote I'm gonna say something crazy your
old man doesn't get a
vote your wife
does yeah a couple of close personal
friends and I want you to begin to this
going to sound so cheesy dude just trust
me on this
when you start to feel less than or
pissed off or angry or I don't even know
what I'm
doing or when someone's like why you're
not getting a masters and you're like no
CU I have 14 other academic advisers I
work with who all have Masters in
$48,000 in student loan debt and they
all make
$35,000 a year well I'm one of those
stupid people I got a master's in a
degree I didn't want even better I have
it listen in the last month how many
people have asked you about your PhD 10
five five exactly listen that's
Insanity yeah and I want you to do
something for me not for me forget that
do it for you I want you to make a fist
with your hand and just just gently rest
it on your chest and think out
loud they don't get a
vote they don't get a
vote and then you have to ask yourself
the terrifying question of what are I
actually want to do what kind of world
do I want to
build what life do me and my wife want
to have what do we want it to feel like
when I get home when she gets
home hey honey how can I best freaking
love you
today what do we want to build
together because here's what you're
doing you're competing with her because
competition is the only way you know how
to
survive because you had a pretty lonely
run of it growing up didn't you
yeah
yeah and so all you know how to do to
stay afloat is to look to your right and
you look to your left and make sure
everybody's heads are bobbing about the
same and then you married an amazing
woman who loves you and you look over
and you're looking like like at her Belt
Line because she's so much she's out of
the water more than you
financially but I bet you bring some joy
to her life that she doesn't have
otherwise
I hope so I know so she wouldn't have
married you ding-dong she's too smart
she makes a lot of
money yeah yeah you're right right so
what do you want to do what do you like
about academic
advising I do like when I kind of see
that light bulb go off in a kid's eye
this the same way when I was coaching
basketball where I finally see you know
the fruits of the labor of what I'm
teaching
start to show itself why don't you coach
basketball
anymore
um I had a job last year where I was and
it didn't pay quite enough so I left
okay but that's that's a job that I
really do love were what level were you
coaching
at uh I was at High School varsity and
then before that I was at H small
division three okay and it just couldn't
cover the bills no yeah
okay my first job out of college was a
high school basketball coach you know
that I did not know that I did that for
two years it's one of my favorite jobs
I've ever had yep I love the camaraderie
with my fellow coaches I was the
youngest guy by 10 or 15 years they
treated me like a son brother and I
loved
him and I love my athletes and my
teammates and and I love the guys the
men Troy kite and Mike Gibson and those
guys and Coach Perkins who helped raise
me
right yeah like my first job and then
they handed us a sheet of paper that
says in 41 years here's what how much
money you're G to make and I said I'm
out right couldn't do it nope and I went
to grad school and got a degree that I
did not use I'm not using
now right but here's the light that
never went out
I love sitting with people who are
hurting I love seeing people take that
next right
step yeah and I've been a high school
teacher I've been a university
administrator I've been a Dena students
I've been a
professor and now I'm I don't even know
what to call what I do
now here's the thing the job has been
the same and when I went backwards I
worked at Burger King for many years and
I loved it when people came in a little
bit deaded a little bit exhausted and I
was able to say dude dud how are you and
they would light up just for the human
interaction here's why I'm telling you
this there's a whole bunch of jobs you
can go do that will light up other
people yeah is that fair no yeah it's
absolutely fair and if you're a guy who
loves
coaching almost every business on planet
Earth needs you in their building right
now almost
everybody cuz people don't know how to
work together for a common goal people
don't know how to say hey are you
okay people don't know how to how to
understand hey if they're not okay
nutritionally and they're not okay at
their home they're not going to be okay
at work we need leaders who know how to
do that that's you
brother thank you you could go get a job
at
Dillard's you could go get a job as a
mid manager at a fill-in the
blank you could take the next three
years and this is what I did working at
a university getting tuition
reimbursement and got another degree in
in mental health
counseling and the school paid for it
you could go do anything man you know
why because you're a coach and you love
people
yeah but here's what I want you to do
with your
wife okay I'm GNA call her Susie okay
okay hope that's not her name if you're
like dude how did you know that'd be
awesome I want you to how long have you
been
married
officially two weeks how are you
unofficially
married all right so two weeks well it's
a long story all right yeah um it's a
long story in a short show so here's the
deal I want you to take her
out okay and and I want you to um
preferably for breakfast or for lunch
and here's why when you take people out
for dinner the lights Get Low people get
kind of tired you have a glass of wine
when you take someone out for breakfast
it's sunny outside and there's just an
optimism and a light to the conversation
it can't happen at your house you have
to go somewhere okay and I want you to
reach across the table and hold her
hands and say you may not know this but
I've been competing with you for who
brings the most into this marriage and
I'm sorry
I've never had a ride or dive partner
until you and I'm going to
practice being a great partner back but
I don't know how and so I'm gonna have
to
practice I want you to say those
words and she's going to go oh my gosh
what are you talking about and be like
well you make way more than me she's
gonna say I promise I don't
care is that what she's going to say yep
yeah and you go I know but I do right
now and I know it's silly
cuz I know all the money goes in our
same checking account and we're both on
the same
team but I want to feel like I'm
contributing
too and then I want you all to have a
discussion about the home you want to
build not the house not the architecture
but we want our house to feel like
this and maybe we want to have kids
someday and that gives us three years
for me to go get another degree or get
some more training or go get another job
outside of the academy which is just
chaos right now or whatever it
is but I want you to invite your wife
into probably the first time of your
life I want you to invite her into I
feel like I'm competing with you I feel
like I'm not enough and let her speak
into it and then say it's hard for me to
believe but I'm going to practice
trusting
you and when you see me feeling less
less than will you just grab my hand and
hold my
hand when I feel less than I'm going to
be honest with
you let I'm going to get my butt out
there I want you to hang on the line I'm
get my butt out there and start finding
a job that actually aligns with who I
want to become um by the way academic
advising amazing you got to have that
job kids come in from all over the world
they don't know up from down or how to
navigate the insanely stupid higher ed
system you got to have academic
advisors uh I want you to hang on the
line I'm going to send you the get clear
um assessment from my friend Ken Coleman
it's an assessment you work through that
will guide you into jobs that you may
not have ever thought about that take
into the things that you were wired to
do that will give you purpose and you
can make a whole bunch of money make a
whole bunch of
money I'm grateful for you
brother whenever you start to do your
wife I want you to ask yourself quietly
has she ever lied to me before no she's
probably not lying now it's probably my
body trying to keep me
safe for the first time in my life I'm
safe now and when somebody asks you what
about that PhD man if you keep working
in four years you're going to be an
senior assistant director and with the
potential track to go to an associate I
want you to put your hand in your chest
and just go they don't get a vote they
don't get a vote they don't get a vote
and if in five years you're still at the
University great good if that's where
you want to be awesome I spent almost 20
years there I loved it but it may not be
for you and that's all
right we when anyone asks you the
question what are you worth the answer
is never a number
the answer is who do I love and who
loves me and you my brother are well
well
loved